[Musique]
un rassemblement somme toute festif mais
un message qui l'est beaucoup moins
festive vu que on sait de c'est plutôt
une année en moins qu'une année en plus
pour la planète il devrait y avoir rien
d'autre chose à faire que de venir ici
il y a rien qui est plus important que
arrêter le réchauffement qui a lieu
présentement
des milliers de montréalé ont marché
pour demander davantage d'action de la
part des gouvernements on demande une
sortie urgente du pétrole et du gaz on
demande une taxation massive de la
richesse et un réinvestissement dans les
services publics
[Applaudissements]
depuis longtemps l'événement de cette
année a un caractère bien particulier le
recul sur le troisième lien c'est une
victoire de la mobilisation citoyenne au
Québec c'est pour ça qu'on manifeste le
sourire aux lèvres aujourd'hui
de telles marches étaient aussi organisé
ailleurs au Québec et au pays notamment
en Mauricie dans la capitale nationale
ou même à Halifax les citoyens demandent
unanimement une accélération de la
transition écologique
mais en amont du 22 avril des
entreprises semblent profiter de la
tenue de l'événement pour faire de
l'écho blanchiment plusieurs estiment
que le Jour de la Terre est récupéré à
des fins lucratives une pratique
vivement dénoncée je trouve un peu
ironique des reprendre ce mouvement-là
puis l'utiliser pour genre les biens des
entreprises on devrait pas
commercialiser Jour de la Terre on
devrait rien vendre le Jour de la Terre
à Montréal la marche est conclue avec un
incident marginal un feu a été allumé
par des manifestants ici aimer Lemieux
Radio-Canada Montréal